[Music]
producers of sesame street's say they
want to have real relevant characters
with hardships that today's kids can
relate to which is why I'm excited to
announce that we are going to
exclusively unveil Sesame Street's
newest character here tonight hey Caleb
how are you yeah pretty good I guess
how was school going not great Conan my
only friend is the janitor I am allergic
to everything on the school lunch menu
and when I'm not getting picked on in
school I'm getting ruthlessly cyber
bullied online well can you tell the
principal he's the one bullying me oh my
goodness is there anything you have to
look forward to Caleb
well tomorrow at school is show-and-tell
great what are you going to
show-and-tell my new case of the measles
thanks a lot Jenny McCarthy Caleb please
before you go I want to give you this
gift it's a bottle full of those our
antidepressants please pills fall out
come on pills we just showed children
how to take a bunch of well visually as
a dark look at a children's show we can
get strong the measles weeks were the
first in comedy to do it congratulations
come on lighten up there's been worse
[ __ ] on the stage would you say there's
been way darker [ __ ] on this stage I
mean come on no I know there has been
darker stuff you know that's not the
point Caleb by the way don't get
defensive can I just say one other thing
[Music]